do you see this mountain range and this
mountain village here's a train weaving
through these mountains and this village
here's a lake at the foot of these
mountains boats ferries fog tunnels I
want to tell you a story of an adventure
I took to a very special place a border
region in Europe it's right here
here's this region from another angle
this is looking south you can see that
this is where Italy ends and Switzerland
begins this is the magical place and
talking about
I want to tell you about this because
this trip perfectly encapsulates what I
think as my recipe for escape I use the
word escape because it kind of feels
like I'm running running away from
something running away from some
incessant pull to do things some
pressure that tells me to work and
produce and do more it's this constant
call to perform for society I kind of
love it in fact this isn't a bad thing
this pressure this intensity it keeps us
all working but the only way that I can
really keep going keep grinding is if I
can escape to pull away and to run away
from everything just for a while
so let me tell you my ingredients for a
real escape number one and the most
important foundational ingredient is
mountains the best escapes happen in the
mountains he doesn't have to be the
mountains of northern Italy or
Switzerland any mountain range will do I
have found escape in mountains from
Oregon to Utah to Spain to Guatemala
even the little mountains near where I
live on the east coast of the United
States Mountains are a perfect place to
escape
[Music]
the mountains are like a filter a border
if you will they block out busyness
there's nothing busy happening in the
mountains everything looks like this
[Music]
it's quiet there's always following
water
there's always mist there's fog and
there are always ecosystems that
manifest themselves in extremes
extremely sharp Peaks
giving way to extremely steep slopes
extremely blue water extremely yellow
trees we explored lots of mountains the
second ingredient happens atop the
mountain it's the mountain village like
this one where the people have been
quietly living their lives for ages
there's no hustle up here there's no
grind there's no one trying to climb any
ladder it is so quiet I haven't heard
this sort of silence for like a year or
more it's so there's no one doing what
I've been doing for the past seven years
which is hustling and grinding to make
something big in some big system no one
is doing that here they're just doing
this
we hit a lot of these little villages on
this trip just a few kilometers over the
Swiss border you can see this one it's
called so glial and it was one of my
favorite places of the trip if not this
entire year we spent the day running
down these trails convincing our
children that these rocks are actually a
playground and finishing the day with a
dinner that looked over these mountains
the town was silent empty we were eating
Italian food but we were in Switzerland
it was perfect ingredient number three
is unplanned adventure my life is really
tightly planned I have two children and
I work like three jobs every day I make
lists of exactly what I can get done in
eight and a half hours and then I work
focusing on each of these items down to
the minute so for me escape looks like
this see that little tiny church all the
way up there it's right there yep we're
gonna turn and we're gonna hike and
we're gonna discover a way to get up to
that mountain do you think we can make
it happen or no
so yeah you can point it a church on a
mountain and just decide that you want
to hike to it maybe you'll make it maybe
you won't I can tell we're in the right
place because if I look up through the
crack up there we're getting closer and
closer these unplanned adventures are
for some reason incredibly restorative
and satisfying for me we made it up to
this level church that I later learned
was called San Martino I had no idea of
the kids would be able to make it up the
side of the mountain but they did it and
they did a great job which made it even
more exciting for some reason the
spontaneity and unplanned nature of this
adventure made it all the more exciting
and all the more restorative for my
brain
[Music]
ingredient number four lakes and fairies
when I was dating is and I looked like
this I would go up to visit her in
Washington Washington State she lived
across the water from Seattle so I'd go
across these ferries a lot I learned to
really love ferries giant boats that are
often a major mode of transportation for
the locals they're cheap they're
frequent and they're totally local no
frills just a bunch of people trying to
get around the place they live in the
ferries in Lake Como bounce around to
different villages you can even take
your car on to these ferries which for
some reason feels kind of awesome you
can also get around on another kind of
boat
[Music]
having a boat to yourself also touches
on the previous ingredient of unplanned
adventure feels like the epitome of
escape you're cruising around a lake
wherever you want you find a village
that looks cool and you end up parking
in the public dock and running around
[Music]
until we decide to jump back on the boat
and do it again
this was our chosen splurge for the trip
and it was well worth it my favorite
part about how we got this boat is you
just find a local guy at a dock and ask
if he can rent his boat and he tells you
yes and before you know it you're
cruising the last ingredient is one that
I have a hard time quantifying I don't
know what to call it or how to even
think about it
but I'm going to call it moving through
mountains in any way any fashion any
mode of transportation with your legs
with a train with a car just moving
through big mountains watching Peaks and
mountain rivers move by you as you
traverse the large daunting mountains
mountain roads always look like they
were designed to be art but somehow
they're incredibly functional to get you
up the steep grade and across the
mountain pass
[Music]
first we drove through these mountains
the boys listening to an audio book
about a frog in a toad and is and I
having long conversations about big
things and little things connecting and
dreaming about the future moving through
these mountains does something to my
brain and I can't really describe it but
it's good it's really good just over the
border from Italy into Switzerland you
can get on a train that takes you over
the Swiss Alps when you're on a train
like this surrounded by large mountains
and moving through them for me my mind
is forced to be right here I'd
successfully escaped any pressure any of
that pulling stress that makes you think
about the thing you have to do it was
all gone we got off in a little town
called post gavel which had a river with
water that was so blue it seemed unfair
we found a little town square and
wandered the town before getting back on
the train and making the journey back
and let me remind you that it doesn't
have to be these quaint beautiful
world-renowned Alps moving through any
mountain range in a train or in a car or
hiking has the same effect for me it's
that mountain effect the mountains
somehow always filter the world away
from me now I love cities and beaches
but when my chest is tight and my brain
is buzzing with stress I know it's time
for an escape so this is my recipe for
escape Mountain Village unplanned
adventures waters and boats and moving
through mountains it's like medicine for
me it cures an overworked brain and
helps me truly restore myself and
reinvigorate the relationships with my
family
a very big thank you to peak design for
sponsoring this video peak design makes
a bag that I have been using for years
ever since I started really doing travel
filmmaking and traveling a lot it's a
very smart camera bag as well as a bag
that I use for a lot of other things
that have nothing to do with cameras
they just launched the version 2 of
their everyday bag which is the bag I've
been using for years and they sent me
one it's still got a lot of the smart
design stuff from the original but it's
got some upgrades that are pretty cool
and I've been having a really fun time
playing around with weatherproof coating
it's got some other kind of subtle
design tweaks in terms of the cuts and
the where the zipper is and exactly
where the pockets are it's got magnets
in the backs of the straps and so the
straps kind of lay like perfectly flat
against the back it's little smart
features like that that really keep me
coming back to peak design they designed
a tripod earlier this year that has
become my new travel tripod I use it for
every project and with this new bag they
increased the size of the water bottle
container so now you can slip the tripod
into it and it won't like swing out for
loic's your support I use this little
key fob and wrap it around the tripod
and connect it to a little Universal
peak connector right there so this is
the new peak design everyday bag this is
the 30 liter and it's just a comfortable
smart bag that's very durable so thanks
peak design as a part of this new launch
they also have a smaller version which
is this zip design which is a little bit
different and I've been using that as
I've been traversing around it through
my drone in here and then of course
their sling which is if I'm just using
the drone and going out and kind of
exploring with the drone and maybe like
one lens or something that I can throw
in here this thing is fantastic it's
super small and easy and it's just a
sling that goes around I have been using
this stuff long before they ever
sponsored by videos and can say they're
great so check out the link in my
description and you can go over to peak
design check out these bags and
hopefully you
like them as much as I do thank you peak
design for sponsoring this video and
thank you for watching this piece on my
trip to Italy and Switzerland it was
really kind of my way of articulating
this feeling of escape that I could have
yearned for after long periods of work
and I hope you enjoyed it
I'll see you next time